Comments like this melt my fucking heart and mean the world to me.
And I like, just don't know the proper words to say
thank you. Like,
it's wild that there's people that care about me and have been like,
kind of following my journey and are excited for me.
Um,
sometimes I let the hate and the ugly comments, like,
win and be louder,
and I hate that, cause then I'm not really connecting with the people,
the point that I'm here,
the point that I'm trying to do in the like this shit.
So I'm sorry to my friends that have followed me.
And then I get like distracted and off into.
Then I go down the rabbit holes of hate.
Um, I'm here for you guys.
The women who see me understand,
they know the fucking deal.
I'm not making shit up, you know what I mean?
We are all like, validating each other and understanding,
like, yeah,
I'm not crazy, you're not crazy.
And so I'm just so thankful
for everybody that's been on this journey with me.
Like, so outrageously thankful.
And the fact that I have like,
people to celebrate the shit with means the world to me.
So, um,
thank you truly,
from the bottom of my fucking heart.
Thank you. I'm so humbled by everybody's kind words.